did you know that a cir torama actually
contributed a lot of the designs for
Dragon Ball's anime only movies like a
lot actually seriously people sometimes
give the Z movies crap for how toy the
villains look but so many of them are
literally Toriyama designs Dr Willow a
Toriyama design Lord Slug another
Toriyama design Bojack Android 13 tapon
all Toriyama designs in fact Toriyama
hand designed every single new character
for the cooler movie and perhaps most
importantly Broly yep you better believe
it Toriyama designed him too in fact
Wrath of the Dragon is actually the only
movie where Toriyama designed barely
anything only contributing the guest
character so by my math that makes herud
dear the most specialist of movie
villains of all time maybe